[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to another episode of what's up
Prof
welcome Walt how are you today Martin
yes I'm good and you I'm still fine
thank you yeah still summer so we're not
complaining about getting
some cold weather no it's very warm yeah
well today's very controversial subject
again and I'm sure we're going to have a
lot to say you know it's a repetitive
subject because it seems that many
people just don't get it no don't want
to get it maybe that's I think closer to
the truth it's open with a word of
Prayer
Heavenly Father
once again it's a privilege to work for
you thank you that we can be here we
have asked your blessing and your
guidance with the Holy Spirit and the
angels protecting us and then also
Enlighten our minds with the discussion
in Jesus name amen amen
well Martin
can we ever work for God or can we only
work with God
work with him yes oh yes if you if you
disconnect that part
you're working in vain you're working in
vain right you're not clocking in for a
job and then clocking out of a job in
fact if it doesn't go with you
you might as well stay behind because
you're going to meet the Enemy by
yourself
you know and if you lag behind it's
going to cut you off
at the back so you better stay close
very close so important actually that
you just ask this
because I think a lot of times when you
work for with God but you
start forgetting that he's with working
with you so you start working for him
that's a problem and you can get tired
of it yes or you don't understand why
you're struggling but the last one you
asked for help is him that's right do
you think you can do it all by yourself
now Martin we're going to talk about
spiritual gifts
I mean we've done it before
and I think we've done it before and I
think we've done it before but we're
going to do it again
now why is it that we have to do these
things
well because
uh people just don't seem to understand
the significance that's the one the
importance
of these things
now just recently a young man contacted
me
brand new
brand plucked from the fire
comes into the church
he's heard a lot of things he's watched
a lot of DVDs
the church is doing the exact opposite
so he has some questions of course they
pop up Ryan that's it
so he goes to the pastor and he says to
the pastor I don't understand you know
why is it that there's meat at the
potluck for example why why are these
things happening what about what the
spirit of Prophecy says
and he gets an answer which says no that
was for the 19th century it's not
applicable to us or it gets an answer
which
is even more stunning The Prophet is
dead so it doesn't apply to us anymore
so we asked the pastor what about
Jeremiah he's also dead does it not
apply to us anymore or Isaiah or any one
of them
but it seems to seems to be a trend and
we've talked about it before okay but
but these articles that come out that
you can't use 19th century literature
the Articles hasn't stopped no so we
can't stop no the Articles don't stop
and I think we've mentioned it before
but to argue that you can't print the
books from the spirit of Prophecy
because it requires trees and we've got
a climate change crisis so we'll have to
stop there
what about all the other garbage that is
printed in the world but that mustn't go
out you know when people start arguing
like that I want to use adjectives
which I best refrain from or else I
could give us a certain line you see
okay and it also is saddening me because
those people that are writing these
articles or pastors that preach this and
or any person that says this is
supposedly part of this church yes they
shouldn't be they shouldn't be answering
I don't mind someone saying let's say
this person this particular person
particularly asks about meat eating
right
uh if if the pastor would say
I know it's right
but we're just not getting it right yet
we're struggling with that uh I hope the
Lord can change our hearts soon I have
no problem with that I don't want to you
know Hammer the thing but to blatantly
say with that's nonsense we don't have
to do that
that uh that crosses a certain line you
know exactly you see the thing is if it
wasn't actually only mentioning the food
any anything that is mentioned do you
treat the Bible the same correct and why
this this ex-union president
with whom I had Crossed Swords before in
a public forum
why he is so anti is of course because
of the sentiments regarding
Catholicism
which he thinks is outdated he's going
to get a big surprise one day yes and I
hope he's ready for it you know
when I read about these things in the
Bible I don't want to go into great
detail with this but
it's so interesting
when you read in the Book of Numbers
about the people of Israel and how they
were
and I just love what Moses had to go
through well I don't love what he had to
go through but I love the responses
because they're so real for our time
when he says to the Lord
when they craved the flesh Foods you
know
he says when shall I have flesh to give
unto all these people for they weep unto
me saying give us flesh that we may eat
I'm not able to Bear all these people
alone because it is too heavy for me and
then he says and if thou thus deal thus
with me kill me I pray thee out of hand
if I found favor in thy sight and let me
not see my wretchedness
and I'm loving when I'm loving because
it's so real she says get rid of me I
can't analysts anymore I can't take it
anymore and you know what
nothing has changed nothing since
Moses's time it's exactly the same why
are you dealing with us with me just
kill me
just give it to me stripe you know just
get rid of me if I have found favor in
your sight then get rid of me isn't that
cute yeah and then the Lord says to him
okay go and get 70 wise men bring them
to the Tabernacle and he gets 70 of them
now did that work out absolutely like it
should have
no well actually no because
when they apply when they came there and
the Lord came down in a cloud and spoke
unto him and took of the spirit
that was upon him and gave it unto the
70 elders and it came to pass that when
the spirit rest upon them they
prophesied but then there's about verse
26.
there are many two of the men in the
camp
so two of those 70 didn't pitch up and
we're going yeah who summoned them God
I'm not going
and uh it's interesting the name of one
was eldad and the name of the other was
medat
but amazingly the spirit rested upon
them and they started to prophesy
so God saw them there in their tent
and he poured the spirit upon them
now Joshua looked at this and he was
disgusted what's going on here
and there ran a young man and told Moses
and said eldad and made that do prophesy
in the camp and Joshua the son of nun
the servant of Moses one of the young
men answered and said my Lord Moses
forbid them stop this immediately
and Moses said unto the envious stuff
for my sake
with God that all the Lord's people were
prophets and that the Lord would put his
Spirit upon them
he was a Meek and gentle man right
so he wasn't too concerned but here they
were prophesying but stubbornness
stubborn
no it sounds familiar now we have the
same thing exactly the same thing and
then Aaron and Miriam oh yeah
thank God all Twitter and bested
and decided that Moses was taking too
much advice from his wife
and they didn't like the fact that she
was Ethiopian says the Bible
and the footnote says or cushite whether
it was so Ellen White says she was
she was not a cushite but she was darker
than the others
and uh just look it looked like that
problem's been around for a long time
we thought this is only popping up now
and then Miriam got a reproof but this
is interesting in verse 6 from chapter
12 it says
hear my words if there be a prophet
among you
I the Lord will make myself known unto
him in a vision and will speak unto him
in a dream
my servant Moses is not so who is
faithful in all mine house
with him will I speak mouth to mouth
even apparently and not in dark speeches
I'll give it to him straight
is it necessary sometimes to get a
straight Testament yeah a straight
testimony because you're so confused you
don't understand what's going on or you
want to be confused but didn't God
always do that didn't he always send a
straight testimony whenever
there was something creeping in that
didn't make it straight okay so there
you can't argue you can't say uh maybe
like that or maybe like not because
he gives it straight right
and the similitude of the Lord shall he
behold wherefore then were you not
afraid to speak against my servant Moses
he's talking to Aaron and Miriam
well you're not afraid
I wonder if some of these pastors or
some of these
so-called leaders that rail against the
spirit of Prophecy
are they not afraid to speak against the
the servant of the Lord exactly are they
not afraid
who who will not be afraid
what spirit is not afraid and you think
of all the books that have been written
and contrary to the spirit of Prophecy
you know
I just want to go on this one this when
I get emails
and then they try to denigrate the
spirit of Prophecy they usually bring up
points against Ellen White
and those points has been the same
points for 170 years why not
because they irk them right and they've
already been debunked
then a hundred times yeah
and mostly when you go back into the
history I've been reading the history
lately
if you go back into that history of all
these people that railed against the
spirit of Prophecy
that were from us but not of us that
went from us
what happened to them they all fizzled
out right
but this message is still going after
all these years why didn't that message
fizzle out right why is it still
irritating everybody today it is you
know what this is the only one that's
standing against the others okay
so I thought we should have a look at
spiritual gifts and perhaps spend a
little time on it because
it is of vital importance
I think it is of Paramount importance
it is so vital that if we do not take
cognizance in my opinion
we're going to miss the boat
I 100 agree and like it says in
Revelation
the requirement to qualify to be the
remnant church as two legs if you the
one is the Commandments the other is the
spirit of Prophecy if you're going to
neglect one you you're gonna have
trouble you're crippled you're crippled
now the interesting thing is Martin
judgment begins with the house of God
and if you've had much light you will be
held responsible for that light even if
you have neglected by choice not to
study the light if it was at your
disposal
it's like having a Bible on the shelf
and never looking into it you are held
responsible for what is in that book
because you had every opportunity to
look into that well that's it
so let's just look at spiritual gifts
and see why we think it is so important
in ancient times God spoke to Men by the
mouth of prophets and apostles
in these days he speaks to them by the
testimonies of his spirit
there was never a time when God
instructed his people more earnestly
than he instructs them now
concerning his will in the course that
he would have them pursue
never a Time
well Martin we are living in the in the
last days
and I think we must we must do a talk
sometime in the future on what does it
mean to be in the last days exactly it's
utmost importance it's important to know
because you know there are those amongst
us who put that day afar off and say
we're not living in the last days
well we've got news for them
we've been living in the last days for 2
000 years so we're living in the last
days whether they like it or not
precisely okay but we're also living at
the end of time yes and that there's a
difference
so we'll have a look at that but there
was never a time when God instructed his
people
more earnestly than he instructs them
now
concerning his will and the course that
he would have them pursue
now you can reject that statement and
say Well it comes from a person who
presumes to be a prophet Tess
it's neglected
but what if it's true
what if it's true
we are laborers together with God
interesting that we started off that way
right
declares Paul writing by the inspiration
of the Holy Spirit In The Struggle
against evil we must put every muscle to
the stretch exercising every god-given
qualification for the right
in order that we may resist temptation
and Advance step by step in the
Christian Life
saved in indolence in inactivity
we can never be
it is not possible for us to drift into
heaven no slugged can enter there
if we do not strive to gain an entrance
into the kingdom
if we do not speak earnestly to learn
what constitutes its laws we are not
fitted to take part in it
but if you become part of a kingdom
let's say you change citizenship and you
become a citizen of the United States of
America do you not swear allegiance to
the Constitution you have to and you
have to abide by their rules if they
have a different rule than here you and
you adhere to this rule you can have
trouble now if that happens in an
Earthly sphere how much more so in the
Heavenly sphere
uh did the first parents
get into trouble for violating those
laws
yes that's the consequence that's why
we're sitting here
okay
so did Jesus say uh Idol into the narrow
on the narrow past into the gate no no
he said strive right well this is very
much an harmony with what the Bible says
it's exactly and you can't put it much
better than it's not possible for us to
drift into heaven no
those who enter there must be loyal and
Faithful Servants of God yoking up with
Christ working his Works overcoming as
he overcame wrestling day after day with
hereditary and cultivated Tendencies to
wrong which must oft be crucified
they must be laborers together with God
unwereed In Prayer their minds
constantly turned heavenward for the
assistance of the Holy Spirit using at
the same time every means that God has
provided for their help
does that sound reasonable I think 100
percent
okay does it sound biblical yes
okay
now let's go to our Pioneers because
this church was started
by the pioneers
and it was based on Bible study
in an atmosphere when there was so much
confusion doctrinal confusion
hundreds of denominations each one
clinging to a Creed yeah
problematic that's why there were so
many denominations because one won't let
go of his Creed so he starts a new
church yes so there were those who
believed that when you're dead you're
sleeping
and they are those that believe that
when you're dead you're not sleeping
you're running around visiting your
relatives doing all kinds of things and
having high positions in heaven no
matter how demonic you were on earth
right
there's there's a difference between
those two doctrines isn't there yeah
totally opposite one of them must be
right and one of them must be wrong or
maybe a third or fourth possibility
right
okay so the Pioneers studied the Bible
they wanted to know what does the Bible
say not what does the Creed say what
does the Bible say
and what do the prophecies say
and these Pioneers when they got to an
impasse and didn't know was it this way
or that way or the other way
the spirit of Prophecy
was the vehicle which showed the way
that's it but it had to be biblical
that's it and it would be either either
be
um in acknowledgment of something that
they studied or like you said showing
the right a direction yes or
out of a plethora
showing the right one and then finding
the verses and saying this is it this is
it
so the Pioneers I've been instructed
that we should make prominent the
testimony of some of the old workers who
are now dead
let them continue to speak through their
articles as found in the early numbers
of our papers these articles should now
be reprinted
that there may be a living voice from
the Lord's Witnesses the history of the
early experiences in the message will be
a power
to withstand the masterly Ingenuity of
Satan's deceptions
this instruction has been repeated
recently I must present before the
people the testimonies of Bible truth
and repeat the decided messages given
years ago
I desire that my servants given at camp
meetings and in churches may live and do
their appointed work
Martin this will take too many trees to
print the paper I think we should you
know discard it discard it
it is so ridiculous I I do not even want
to comment because I will jump out of my
skin yeah but unfortunately this was
written 119 years ago so it's also all
something and after all she's dead yeah
so but
old workers who are now dead we have to
make prominent their testimony all right
at least we're not using paper
but we're using electricity and putting
a carbon front and footprint into the
air maybe that will also be problematic
but then the writer of those articles
also put a carbon footprint into the air
so I think we're quits right yeah okay
let's not let's not joke about them
anymore but no but this is the the sad
part is this is a very big part of the
church that has the sentiment
and we have to show if that sentiment is
in harmony with harmony harmony with the
Bible
if you were to come to me tomorrow or
anyone else in the church
and say to me that you are now a prophet
I would be overjoyed right and do
everything you say
now I would be exactly skeptical
exceedingly skeptical
so these Pioneers don't you think they
were exceedingly skeptical as well
definitely
so what convinced them the truth the
truth must have convinced them the proof
of the pudding was always in the eating
right you cannot deny when truth is
presented you can try and disregard it
but you're not gonna you cannot deny
that it's truth now there's one Pioneer
that uh you know impresses me
because here is ABS and he had his Downs
it was very hard working very faithful
and his name was Uriah Smith
and he wrote a number of books and he he
put forward a number of theses
and he didn't always get it absolutely
right
but uh he was also
rebuked at the stage
but he was he was so on fire you know
his history is so interesting he had
this this leg problem he didn't his one
leg was gone so he invented the
prosthesis that had a a jointed knee in
a jointed ankle and to this day that
patent is used in the world and by the
militaries of the world Etc these people
had gumption
and when they discovered the truth and
the law and they built up the church and
this dichotomy of Law and Grace and all
of these issues were in the church it
wasn't easy no obviously to work your
way through that Quagmire but I think he
in the end
managed to jump many a hurdle
yeah there was a time when he was let's
say not so very fond of the spirit of
Prophecy idea it was always for the
spirit of Prophecy but when he was
wrapped over the knuckles well that
sounds familiar it must have been
painful
especially when young upstarts
were taking the Limelight like Alfonso T
Jones
here was this young man
and he was talking about righteousness
by faith
and
Uriah Smith and some of the older folks
were thinking you know they're taking
away obedience to the law and they
wanted to put the brakes on and Alfonso
was extremely fiery
and somewhat arrogant
and then the spirit of Prophecy is sided
with Jones
and that was the you know being painful
and I can understand why I was upset
because Jones took a number of swipes at
him
because he had been very prolific in
writing
and one of the issues that he was one of
the first to unravel was the ten toes of
Daniel who they were or the ten horns
who they were
and he mentioned you know the nations of
Europe
but he didn't include the al-amani which
are the Germans he had the Huns in his
list
and Alfonso Jones studied this issue in
great detail and deleted the hands
as not part of of that category and he
put the alamani in there
and then somebody would ask him publicly
well what do you think about the fact
that you know our Pioneers that Uriah
Smith said it was the Huns
and then he would say things publicly
more or less in in this line
uh Uriah Smith thinks it's the arms but
I know it's the alimony
and they must have smarter
the way that he did it was also not good
it was not very nice and so all of these
things but you know you go all the way
that's it and you look at the end of the
matter oh but that's so important
because a lot of times people will go to
a Pioneer and just go to his beginning
correct they never go
the full course now some of them
did go off the rails in the end yes so
you have to have
clear discernment of which way to go
there you have to you have to separate
the message from the man
oh that's that's it you have to the
message must come in harmony with two
things with the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy that's it but it's interesting
that Uriah Smith who was the editor of
the review
later was replaced by Alfonso T Jones
who was much younger than him and the
Uriah Smith worked basically under him
and he did it
that takes a lot you know to swallow
that Pride that sounds like Paul with
Mark yes and he's smartered for two
years Uriah
and he had he had all of these things
come down upon him and he had a couple
of sympathizers of the old guys
but he came round in the end and then he
gave a sermon one day let's read about
that
this is Uriah Smith's Spirit of Prophecy
sermon
the second Sabbath of the of the session
Uriah Smith gave the morning worship
sermon his topic was the spirit of
Prophecy and our relation to it
choosing as his main text 1 Corinthians
12 1
. now concerning spiritual gifts
Brethren I would not have you ignorant
he used the scripture of the scripture
in presenting a strong biblical basis
for the position that the prophetic gift
would appear in Earth's last days he
climaxed this phrase of his address by
introducing Revelation 12 17. as
justification for accepting the position
for this operation of the spirit to be
expected
now he must put this into the historic
context
for two years Smith's influence had been
negative he opposed the righteousness by
faith message he didn't deny
righteousness by faith
he just believed there was too much
emphasis on the one side rather than on
the other side you know he wanted a
little bit of wax in there
so his influence had been negative for
two years he said little about the
spirit of Prophecy because he had been
rebuked
as manifested in the life and work of
Ellen White but a few weeks before
preaching this sermon
he had fallen on the rock as Ellen White
put it now everyone saw where he stood
and it brought strength and confidence
to the people
you know there are people that are
very hard
on the church and say that the church in
its entirety rejected the righteousness
by faith message that's not true
there are those that rejected it but
here you have the case of Uriah Smith
he was opposed to the way in which it
was presented and of course the the
person the little smacks that he got
and here he is falling on the rock
and then bringing this sermon to the
front
so this is what I think I think these
Pioneers battled like we battle
they were human and like all of us like
he did need to break on the Rock and to
surrender our stubborn natures
Uriah must have had a battle raging
within himself but his final conclusion
I think is worthy of consideration
so I went and looked up
Uriah Smith's sermon I found it in one
of those big books
I can't find it on the web yeah so I
found it in one of those big books that
sort of had photocopies of what was
written in those days
and I thought it was worth sharing
so shall we go through oh please just
the basics yeah not his whole sermon it
would take too long
but just the basically that we can get a
grasp of someone that has realized like
she mentioned fallen on the Rock yes
what happens to that person yes he was
he was he was one of the Pioneers he was
at the heart of the work he was in
leadership
he was basically humiliated
and he had people with him in a little
group he could have separated
but he didn't he fell on the Rock he
could have said no these lots have
become Babylon I must get out of them he
was in a high position
and he was willing to take a lower
position
you know somebody like that can be
exalted by the God always the universe
don't you think God he said we Jesus
came to be a servant
yes
so this is basically what his sermon was
about and I think we have to expand on
that a little bit later and see what
what is the the aim the objective with
the spirit of Prophecy
why if it is such a tremendous stumbling
block do we need it at all
why did the people need Moses
of course they would have been a lot of
nightmare if they he wasn't there if he
wasn't there where would they have gone
eh what would they have done
I mean if when it with him there it was
already a nightmare all right well here
he took the children of Israel out of
Egypt and he took them to Canaan
all the way there
now in the end of time when the people
must come out of Babylon and must go all
the way to the anti-typical
Babylon you're just going to leave them
to do their own thing
will have a case worse than Babylon
it'll be confusion like you cannot
believe
so something like this is absolutely
necessary so let's look what he did
so any sermon
sometimes I quote him word for word but
mostly I paraphrase
he says there are two things that the
Apostle Paul writes about that he does
not want us to be ignorant of
one is in 1 Corinthians 12 1 where he
writes now concerning spiritual gifts
Brethren I would not have you ignorant
is it important yes
obviously to Paul it's important right
there's another one
about which he doesn't want us to be
ignorant one Thessalonians 4 13. but I
would not have you be ignorant brethren
concerning them which are asleep
that ye sorrow not even as others which
have no hope
Martin or both of these bones of
contention
a lot
a lot because right so we have a big
bone of contention about spiritual gifts
and we have a big bone of contention
about the state of the Dead
which will be one of the state of the
Dead will be one of the last deceptions
that Satan will use Satan will not be
able to succeed with these deceptions
unless
he leans on his doctrine of immortality
so both are highly significant when it
comes to the restoration of all things
and the assignment of the remnant Church
Paul does not wish us to be ignorant
regarding these two issues because the
correct understanding of them is vital
to the church and particularly to the
remnant as they must face the Demonic
delusions of the last days head on
a correct understanding of these vital
points guards against the inroads of
spiritualism
and fortifies against the spurious
interpretations of the scriptures
isn't that powerful
you know what
so in other words
when you adhere to these things
you will have the correct understanding
of what the Bible means you will at
least be in a position to have the
correction understanding
it is so important that we that we look
into this issue
he quotes second Peter 3 verse 16 as
also in all his Epistles speaking in
them of these things this is Peter
writing about the writings of Paul
and which are some things hard to
understand
which they that are unlearned and
unstable rest as they do also the other
scriptures unto their own destruction
so the question is
this resting of scripture
so they twist it yes
was it a situation in the days of the
Apostles yes will it be one at the time
of the end
and all the times in between cannot do
any other
and then of course this famous verse
Revelation 12 17 and the Dragon
was Wrath with a woman and went to make
war with the remnant of her seed which
keep the Commandments of God and have
the testimony of Jesus Christ
not believe
have the testimony of Jesus Christ
so spiritual gifts are vital to the
church
and it is important that we understand
them
I do not want you to be ignorant
or put in another way I want you to
understand it
the workings of the Holy Spirit are
mystery
but it is the medium whereby Grace comes
to the church the comforter the spirit
of Truth The Spirit of Hope the spirit
of Glory
you can look all of those up in the
concordance and you will find them
so
we're still on a Biblical track because
we're reading scripture yeah
and then he turns to the spiritual gifts
themselves and says all right what does
Paul not want us to be ignorant of and
why
now concerning spiritual gifts Brethren
I would not have you ignorant ye know
that you were gentiles
carried away unto these dumb Idols even
as you were LED
so in idolatry
whatever the idols did you did
so if they loaded the idol on a cart and
transported it you trudged after it
chanting some silly thing and that Idol
can neither speak nor hear nor do
anything and yet voices were heard at
these idols
and a lot of skull daggery and nonsense
took place there but a lot of demonic
activity as well whatever was said that
was it
wherefore I give you to understand that
no man speaking by the spirit of God
calls Jesus a curse and that no man can
say that Jesus is the Lord
but by the Holy Ghost
very brilliant text
so one of the first things if you want
to know about truth if Christ is not
Central in that truth it's not truth
because the spirit of God will lead you
to that truth exactly so and of course
paying lip service to A Jesus yes it's
not the same as the true one and of
course the modern translations so uh
brutalize this text that they have Jesus
basically or Paul cursing Jesus in the
text
but uh let's not go there because that
is another mute point on which we have
labored in the past
1 Corinthians 12 4 now there are
diversities of gifts but the Same Spirit
that's a very important point
there are different gifts but they come
from the same Spirit yes they have to be
christ-centered if they're not they're
not from God
and there are differences of
administration but the same Lord
and there are diversities of operations
but the same God which worketh all in
all so there are many things that have
to happen in a church
there has to be organization there has
to be Administration there has to be
operation and God leads people to do
their particular tasks
but the manifestation of the spirit is
given to every man to profit with all
in other words it's not a gift for you
personally to bask in no it's always for
service if it doesn't strengthen the
church if it's only for an individual or
like you said itself then it cannot be
and I'm thinking about a certain one
that they a certain gift the one tongues
that they
misconstrue correct
somebody that's speaking in tongues in
some Churches speaks a language that
nobody can understand in there it
doesn't do anything for the uplifting of
the church exactly then you know it's
not one of the gifts
and then he will continue and he'll say
what some of these gifts are
for to the one is given by the spirit
the word of wisdom
to another the word of knowledge
by The Same Spirit
to another Faith by The Same Spirit to
another the gifts of healing by The Same
Spirit to another the working of
Miracles to another prophecy to another
Discerning of spirits to another diverse
kinds of tongues to another
interpretation of tongues
is repeating that over and over to
another to another to another
because in paganism everybody is Led
along and has the same manifestations
here there are different gifts given by
God to different people different
individuals I was just thinking when
before I became a Seventh-Day Adventist
we were in a charismatic church
and we went through Bible study of the
gifts of the spirits
but at the end especially the gift of
tongues yes everybody had to have it
right everybody has to have it and if
you don't have it you have to pray and
ask God to help you and it's actually
that's a manifestation outward
manifestation to show that you've got
the spirit is that and that's not
biblical no because like you've just
said not everyone can have it's supposed
to have the same one yes and besides the
fact that they had the wrong application
for the gift of tongues it was literal
languages in their mother tongue they
could speak the languages in the mother
tongue of the other language so for
instance if we can take make it easy uh
they were say for instance Peter could
speak German
and the german-speaking persons in the
there good understanding yes in their
own dialect even as they were born
but all these work that one and the
self-same spirit dividing every man
severally as he will not as you will as
he will that spirit is the Holy Spirit
correct and
that decision is made by God
who gets what gift it's not yours to
choose
and then Uriah says to make matters
plainer the Apostle proceeds to compare
these gifts to the functioning of a body
where all the members have specific
assignments but they all work in unity
of purpose
that's the importance so none of these
gifts are for a selfish purpose
and then he continues so that a church
without these gifts is just like a man
some of whose members have become
diseased disabled or removed
and just so with the church when these
gifts are lacking and these members
inoperative it is a church which cannot
perform its whole Duty in the world for
the benefit of the Human family
if those gifts aren't there
it's a malfunctioning organization
from verse 28 onwards the Apostle lists
the gifts in order of importance and
qualifies that not all have the gifts or
the same gifts
and God has said some in the church
first apostles secondarily prophets
thirdly teachers after that Miracles
then Gifts of healing helps governments
diversities of tongues
so that you are not ignorant on the
subject
are all apostles
the answer is obviously no not are all
prophets no no are all teachers no no
are all workers of Miracles no have all
the gifts of healing no
do all speak with tongues no do all
interpret no
but covet earnestly the best gifts and
yet so I unto you a more excellent way
you have to be a Christian in heart and
mind and soul and leave the gift-giving
to God
and then because it's a very important
subject in Ephesians the pastor explains
when by whom and for what purpose and
for what duration
where the gifts introduced right
Ephesians 4 verse 8. wherefore he says
when he ascended up on high he led
captivity captive and gave gifts unto
men
so the gifts come from Jesus Christ yes
Ephesians 4 11. and he gave some
Apostles some prophets some evangelists
some pastors teachers
that's the same list more or less with a
couple of things missing and he says for
the perfecting of the Saints so that's
the purpose
for the work of the ministry
for the edifying of the body of Christ
very important so obviously if this is
missing
that won't be manifest in the church so
if if everything goes awry and there's
no Prophet to set it straight
it can continue to go awry
all right
till we come into the unity of the faith
and of the knowledge of the Son of God
unto a perfect man unto the measure of
the stature of the fullness of Christ
so here are two possibilities Martin
if you are not in unity
there are two possibilities there's no
prophet
or some disregard the prophet
you know I've four years said exactly
that same words if you want Unity there
has to be Unity around the prophet
because then you'll have Unity around
the Bible then you'll have Unity now if
you take
in some of those Israelite Kings
is there no prophet in Israel yes
there's one but I hate them yes because
the other 400 or whatever no they bring
the prophets of Baal they they're okay
but that other one I hate him why
because he doesn't he tells you the
truth right
now do we have the same situation today
Perfect all right
does that mean everybody in the church
or that the entire church is apostate no
no
but it's time to start acknowledging and
give
time to studying the prophet okay so
when you come into Unity of the faith
and the knowledge of the Son of God
that's the faith of Jesus
unto a perfect man unto the measure of
the stature of the fullness of Christ
that's what we have to grow up to right
so I understand that the testimony of
Jesus
actually means what Jesus has said yes
and if he says it to a prophet and the
prophet says it to you and you say it's
not worth cutting down a tree to make
the paper to spread it with then there's
a serious problem with your thinking it
is because then you say okay Jesus I
don't want to hear what you're actually
saying correct
that we henceforth be no more children
tossed to and fro and carried about with
every wind of Doctrine by the slight of
men and cunning craftiness whereby they
lie in way to deceive
do we have all of those things in the
church every wind of Doctrine
do we have slight of men do we have
cunning craftiness
do we have deception
don't even go there Martin
sign one Corinthians it is confirmed
that those who are waiting for the
coming of Christ will be blessed with
all the gifts of the Spirit
1 Corinthians 1 6 even as the testimony
of Christ
was confirmed in you so that you come
behind in no gift
waiting for the coming of our Lord Jesus
Christ must all the gifts be there does
that include the gift of Prophecy yes
or maybe maybe especially because the
gift of Prophecy will help you
acknowledge that the other ones actually
exist all right so yeah all of those
listed
and these are the gifts
now he says you come behind in no gift
waiting for the coming of the Lord that
gift must be restored now it's very
interesting when this was written
because here says testimony of Christ
it's the same as the testimony of Jesus
right
so addressing the people that will be
expecting the soon return of Christ he
writes
in first Thessalonians but of the times
and Seasons brethren
ye have no need that I write unto you
for yourselves know perfectly that the
day of the Lord so cometh as the thief
of the in the night
so that's what the scripture says right
for yourselves know perfectly that the
day of the Lord so cometh as a thief in
the night
for when they shall say peace and safety
then sudden destruction cometh upon them
as travail upon a woman with child and
they shall not Escape but then he says
but ye that's plural
brethren
are not in darkness that that day should
overtake you as a thief why not why not
good question why should it not overtake
them as a thief because they've got the
spirit of Prophecy and they have the
gift that's it and now you have the full
plethora you do not have to be in
darkness you can choose to be in
darkness
but you do not have to be in darkness
ye are all the children of light and the
children of the day we are not of the
night nor of the darkness how come the
darkness has been dispelled
sorry
hey therefore let us not sleep
as do others but let us watch and be
sober
now the remnant is lukewarm
and I assume that some of them are
asleep because the ten virgins they all
went
so whether some of woken up or not is
still to be demonstrated right
and then from verse 19 onwards he says
first Thessalonians 5 19.
quench not the spirit
despise not prophesying
prove all things hold fast that which is
good now remember we're dealing with the
sermon of Uriah Smith yes he is digging
all of this up
I think these Pioneers were very
thorough now you must also remember he
was kind of kicking against this for two
years he was kicking against the bricks
it wasn't that's what company did Paul
kick against the bricks Martin did you
kick against the Pricks in the beginning
that's why I made a sermon about it okay
all right I I kicked against the pricks
I mean who was going to give up your
entire way of life and say okay what is
this person this Prophet have to say
I'll do it exactly you have to be either
insane or highly motivated so now you
must know how God worked on him and now
it started to bother him and then
eventually I had to say okay let me look
at this again this is what comes from it
this is what comes from it so number one
don't quench the spirit that's a
Biblical injunction
and let's listen to how he deals with
the prophesyings I've put it in inverted
commas here because I'm quoting him now
he says quench not the spirit an
important injunction
despise not prophesying
it doesn't say prophecies
it says prophesying's present active
participle
in other words somebody is telling you
something right now
it's not saying I want you to study the
Book of Daniel and not to despise it I
want you to study the book of Isaiah it
doesn't say that it says despise not
prophesying present active participle
prove all things check it out otherwise
you are a fool it let me think of that
when
Jesus when they asked him I think you
made a sermon about it as well come and
see yes come and see that's the same
all things come and see come and see
indicating a present active principle
that needs to be tested by the word to
differentiate between the true and the
spurious
it's brilliant
it's brilliant to put it together like
that
John 14 verse 6 and I will pray the
father and he shall give you another
comforter that he may abide with you for
how long Martin forever does that
include the end of time when the Canon
has already been fixed yes
all right even the spirit of Truth
whom the world cannot receive because
it's seeth not neither knoweth him but
ye know him for he dwelleth with you and
shall be in you so those gifts will be
there till when
forever forever for the till the end of
time
so the Apostle Peter quotes the prophet
Joel as a fulfillment of the promise of
the outpouring of the Holy Spirit
that's at Pentecost I said you were
drunk he says no no no we're not drunk
this is what was spoken about by the
prophet Joel
so if we read it there in Acts 2 from
verse 15 for these are not drunken as
you suppose seeing it is but the third
hour of the day that means it was nine
o'clock in the morning
but this is that which was spoken by the
prophet Joel and it shall come to pass
in the last days see there we have that
term last days
said God I will pour out my spirit upon
All Flesh and your sons and your
daughters shall prophesy and your young
men shall see visions and your old men
shall dream dreams and O my servants and
on my handmaidens I will pour out in
those days of my spirit and they shall
prophesy
so the last days must have applied to
them as well because the outpouring of
the Holy Spirit took place at Pentecost
will it be neglected at the latter right
yeah no
sorry will the
outboarding be neglected sorry I was
thinking will the gift be neglected
either way
the outpouring won't be neglected there
will be an outpouring because the bible
promises the latter rain
and it promises the gifts until the end
so Paul warns that after his departure
Grievous wolves would come in
he says in verse 29 of Acts 24 I know
this that after my departing shall
grieve as wolves enter in amongst you
not sparing the flock
also of your own selves shall men arise
speaking perverse things to draw away
disciples
after them
so error will come into the church right
and people will flock after that
do Grievous wolves make the gifts
obsolete
no no
or do they necessitate greater vigilance
and Direction yes did the gift cease of
the Pentecost or were they promised to
those who repented and do future
Generations yes
well we can read it then Peter said in
Acts 2 38
repent and be baptized every one of you
in the name of Jesus Christ for the
remission of sins and you shall
receive the gift of the Holy Ghost
for the promise is unto you his time
to your children future
and to all that are afar off even as
many as the Lord Our God shall call so
for how long will they be till the end
of time till the end of time
now the question is why have the gifts
not continued in the church
and what they at some stage be restored
that's what Uriah Smith asks why have we
had this death
you know the Middle Ages and everything
that happened there
so Uriah Smith concludes that the
churches put up a barrier against the
workings of the Spirit by introducing a
Creed
not a bad idea you know
a Creed and the spirit he says cannot
dwell together
so the church scattered and fragmented
prophesied in sackcloth in the
wilderness without the full
manifestation of the gifts of the Spirit
they were still there in a little pocket
here in a little pocket there
so these gifts will according to
prophecy be restored in the last days
because the latter rain is an even
greater manifestation than the early
rain
does that make sense
definitely especially if you take the
scope of what the latter rain entails
okay
and then we jump to that verse again
and the dragon Revelation 12 17 was
Wrath with the woman
and went to make war with the remnant of
a seed
which keep the Commandments of God and
have the testimony of Jesus Christ so
the seed of the woman is the number of
Believers in any generation
and the remnant of a seed is the last
generation and they will have the
special feature of the testimony of
Jesus which according to Revelation 19
10 is the spirit of Prophecy right
so the church when it prophesied in the
wilderness
did it have gifts yes it must have had
otherwise it couldn't have prophesied
right who was leading it the spirit was
the spirit was
the spirit of Prophecy was present in
the form of scripture and so the
reformers that's a very good point
Martin
the reformers took hold of the testimony
which is in the scripture which are the
prophetic writings
but remember Paul also says do not
despise prophesying yes but they said
solar scriptira is the basis for all
truth and that stands for all eternity
yes any prophesying
has to be in harmony with that testimony
so where does this leave us if these two
criteria are to be in the remnant the
dragon is wrath because they keep the
Commandments and they have the testimony
and then he says that in everything you
are enriched by Him in all utterance and
in all knowledge
even as the testimony of Christ was
confirmed in you
past tense
so what Christ has said what is written
in the word that must be in you so that
you come behind in no gift
waiting for the coming of our Lord Jesus
Christ
if there are all the gifts does that
include the gift of Prophecy exactly aha
so the remnant there will have the gift
of Prophecy
so Paul here connects the testimony of
Jesus with the gifts the letter to the
Corinthians was written in 59 A.D
before the Book of Revelation was
written which is further proof that the
testimony of Jesus is associated with
the gifts and Revelation 19 10 specifies
which gift in particular that's it there
is the qualifying criteria yes he and
it's so important because a lot of
people those that want to say nah it's
part of the past it's the past we're not
going to have it anymore but here it's
very very clear and this is Paul writing
and then you have this very clear
definition in Revelation 19 10 that the
testimony of Jesus is the spirit of
Prophecy and the remnant will have the
testimony of Jesus in other words the
prophet so it's that Spirit of Prophecy
is not only referring to the old
prophets in the bible correct
so the remnant must have the gifts
restored so the superstitions and errors
of the past must have been cast aside
and the true church must fulfill the
criteria of the Song of Solomon where it
says Thou Art beautiful o my love
as tirsa calmly as Jerusalem terrible as
an army with banners who is she that
looketh forth as the morning fair is the
moon clear as the sun and terrible as an
army with banners
it's a war wasn't the Devil wroth with
the woman and when to make war war
against the remnant okay let me reverse
that phrase
if the devil is making war with a woman
is the woman then not at war with the
with the devil yeah
so she's an army and she is an army
terrible as an army with banners
now whenever there was a banner it stood
for a particular thing
it was a sign it was an enzyme and their
Banner is the Commandments of God
including the Sabbath
because it's all of them because if you
stumble at one point you stumble at them
all
so can we conclude then that after the
great disappointment the great truths of
the sanctuary and the age-old doctrines
of the true state of the Dead
the law and the testimony were placed in
right settings under the guidance of the
gift and the gift of Prophecy in
particular
the church was warned against giving up
the ancient paths and to lead the church
and the restoration of all truth
thus setting a right the character of
God and preparing a people to stand in
the day of the Lord
it admonished the people to set aside
their minor differences and to unite in
the one great movement of the third
Angels message
that's why the gifts had to be restored
is there any denomination in the world
out there
other than the Seventh Day Adventist
denomination that preaches the Three
Angels messages no
are all within the church happy where
the Three Angels messages no no
unfortunately are some exceedingly
opposed to the preaching of the Three
Angels messages yes yes but don't the
tears grow together with the wheat yes
until when Martin
until the Harvest ah
so because there are tears in the church
that say we cannot hand out Spirit of
prophecy books because we've got climate
change
does that make the whole church obsolete
no
does this church have the spirit of
Prophecy yes uh-huh all right someone
this is very very important
so Uriah Smith basically asks a few
questions I think he asks about 15 or 16
questions but I'll only deal with about
three or four maybe
does The Seventh-Day Adventist Church
accept the writings of Ellen G white to
be a revelation from God
officially yes
yes
unofficially since some people that
sometimes sometimes some are on a
climate change bandwagon
if the answer is in the affirmative
then ask the question on what grounds do
you accept the writings to be a
revelation from God isn't that an
important question definitely
that's the ground
did you do without a Bible study did we
just do a Bible studying
so in that Bible study have we found
that the gifts will be there till the
end of time even though the Canon is
complete
have we found out that the remnant will
have specifically that gift which is
called the testimony of Jesus which is
the spirit of Prophecy will it have it
yes why well we just have to look at
what happened in the past for the sake
of unity right
so on what grounds do you accept the
writings to be a revelation from God
surely if we say we accept them
then they must comply with every
condition set forth in the word of God
and they must be in harmony with the
word of God
it must lead to God it must lead to
Christ because that's the very first
thing that the gifts have to do
it must open up the Plan of Salvation
And it must bring reproof and warning to
the church and through the church to the
world yeah you see the problem with the
spirit of Prophecy for most people is
the last two part of this that they
don't like proof and the warning to the
church and then they turn away
especially when they have to bring those
reproofs to the world okay all right now
the prophets of old did they bring
reproof even to Kings oh yes whether
it's thrown into the systems and into
the mire where they Saun asunder
wasn't it a king that had Isaiah sown in
half and there was a king of Judah it
was Manasseh yes it was one of God's
people's King okay now the the strangest
thing of all
is he had second thoughts
Manasseh
he had a little bit of a letdown he was
he was taken away and he returned to his
kingdom was restored to his kingdom and
tried to make right what he had done
wrong Manasseh will be in heaven one day
amazing so this is such an interesting
all of us will have a second
time
you're quite right Martin that's a very
very good point
all right next question does the gift of
Prophecy have to be underpinned with
miracles signs and wonders
in other words must you see great
manifestations taking place obviously
not
the gift themselves of their own
evidence and if the past is a clue to
the Future then the gift of Prophecy was
distributed only under special
circumstances
and to a few chosen individuals
there weren't hundreds of prophets there
was a Jeremiah there was an Isaiah
sometimes there were two or three
prophets at the same time like Ezekiel
and Daniel and Etc but they weren't all
prophets not even Nehemiah was a prophet
he was an administrator he had the gift
of administration
but the gift was there what and I can
also just ask a question here was that
Prophet always in a war with a lot of
prophets
like for instance Elijah and they were
always falling they were always hundreds
of false prophets against one yes and
there were always those that didn't want
to be separate they were always running
to Assyria in the early stages or then
later to Syria making alliances and
trying to make alliances with Babylon
and communism a communism do we have
these fellows today who even tried to be
Vice chairs of these organizations is
there no God in Israel
all honored Apostles and all are not
prophets but if one had the gift
then it's in the church yeah
then it's in the church it's enough it's
enough
next question will it be popular and
universally accepted
there's no way
and if you test it and you study it
thoroughly you will find that the
critics have got it wrong right
say if they called The Master of the
House belzaboop and said he had a devil
well they're not the same say the same
of his servants
the dragon does not get wrath over
Trifles this is Uriah Smith
musing away
the dragon does not get wrath over
Trifles the dragon does not get Roth
over a dead Church
what excites his Wrath
it is the two features which Stand
Together which excite his wrath namely
The Obedience to the Commandments of God
and the testimony of Jesus that irks him
yes so when those two are in a church
and there's Unity you can expect some
trouble from
and you can expect hundreds of prophets
of bail within that same church but
sooner or later a showdown is coming
and the Lord God will answer with fire
from heaven the outpouring of the latter
rain and the people
well some will answer him not a word
but others will see and come in droves
into this church
so the doctrine of spiritual gifts is
treated in the scriptures as of vital
importance to the the church
and slighting the spirit is a serious
obstacle to spiritual growth and the
scriptures admonish us in 1
Thessalonians 5 19 quench not the spirit
don't pour cold water on the Fire
as a people we will soon have to face
the ire of the Dragon
we are facing it already right
and if we quench not the spirit then the
latter rain can be poured out upon us
and we can be part of the loud cry
that will gather God's people from the
four corners of the Earth
we are called to be stewards of the word
and stewards of present truth
1 Corinthians 4 2 says moreover it is
required in students
that a man be found faithful
so Martin how important is it
and having studied spiritual gifts
we take a look at the writings of the
spirit of Prophecy put them to the test
and if they are from God
accept them that's it and quench not the
spirit so do what it says do what it
says don't leave it for later
and I would like to even issue a warning
that it will be more tolerable
for some
and it would be better to put the melts
down around their necks
than to make one of the least of the
little ones stumble in this regard
if they are from God
then it is the testimony of Jesus
and that means that we have to obey them
oh treat it like it is yes yes and if
you study it through
you will find that it is good for you
it's not a yoke my yoke is easy it's
like the Commandments it's like the
Commandments it's not a yoke it is a
help it is an aid
and it is the right thing to do and it
will bring happiness and it will bring
joy even in strife and adversity you
will have an anchor to lean on
and you will know that the
interpretation of scripture that you are
following is backed by the testimony of
Jesus
Heavenly Father
this topic
has to be agitated over and over and
over again
and there will always be opposition to
it
but help us to study it
and if we have studied it to make a
decision
is my prayer in Jesus name amen amen
[Music]
thank you